l'alba a sanremo in provenza
un piccolo però del sud
un ragazzo passeggiava qua e là nei
sobborghi del paese e giusto in piazza
guardandosi intorno notò una piccola
locanda nell'angolo e via via a seguire
una lunga schiera di case seguiva un
viale ciottolato che poco più in là
lasciava spa spazio agli immensi e
scoscesi campi di lavanda delle campagne
francesi
adoro il profumo della lavanda
a quell'ora della notte il ragazzo nota
un'altra figura oltre a lui che faceva
capolino al di là del bancone della
locanda
quasi inquietante
si guardano intorno
e capi che ogni cosa che guardava
appare gli appariva come se fosse appena
stata dipinta
come se un pittore fosse passato di lì e
avesse dato un colpo di pennello a
qualsiasi cosa
porte case muri tetti qualsiasi cosa
notato questo il ragazzo
alzo gli occhi verso il cielo e capi che
anch'esso appariva degli stessi colori e
delle stesse sfumature del paesaggio
colori quali il blu
azzurro il nero il verde e il giallo
peccato
già è davvero un peccato che quel
ragazzo non portasse con sé un telefono
per immortalare quel memorabile momento
sono convinto però che nel telefono di
ognuno di noi ci sono immortalate scene
belle di momenti felici e spensierati
ma una domanda un dubbio mi sorge
spontaneo ma questi momenti sono davvero
vissuti al cento per cento
o per meglio dire se non gli avessimo
rivisti in foto ce li ricorderemo
comunque
per provare a rispondere a questo
quesito prendete tutti quanti il vostro
telefono in questo momento prendetelo
tutti quanti e stretto da qualsiasi
posto
aprire la galleria fotografica è
iniziato a scorrere le foto
notate quanti momenti belli e felici
riaffiorano alla vostra memoria e che
magari erano seppelliti chissà dove
sono tanti e belli spero
ora
c'è da fare una piccola distinzione però
che cos'è il bello o per meglio dire che
cos'è la bellezza
devo ammettere che non ci sono molti
aggettivi attribuibile alla parola
bellezza una volta che si prova davvero
né si verrà subito colpiti
la bellezza è una specie di armonia
visiva che penetra soavemente nei cuori
umani
questo è ugo foscolo
la vera bellezza è sempre misteriosa si
sente ma non si può dire
goffredo parise
la bellezza è un aggressività stupenda
in grado di far distogliere il pensiero
dalle situazioni precarie
e questo ero io
molto bello bellissimo
quante volte di fronte ad un dipinto
come in questo caso lo abbiamo definito
bello senza però fondamentalmente avere
le conoscenze per poterlo giudicare
sono solo parole di rito dette talvolta
però non apparire ignoranti e stupidi di
fronte agli altri
sono convinto però che le stesse parole
dette in altri momenti sarebbe sarebbero
pronunciate con molta più limpidezza e
sincerità
prendiamo ad esempio un tramonto
avrete presente tutti un tramonto è un
evento naturale che potremmo definire
indiscutibilmente bello bello perché
opera della natura
a differenza delle opere artificiali
discutibili
ora arrivati a questo punto voglio
raccontarvi un piccolo aneddoto
come capita e capiterà e sicuramente
sarà capitato a tutti voi
mi sono innamorato
per come sono fatto
ho subito inondato questa ragazza di
attenzione piccole attenzioni grandi
per cinque mesi inoltrati il mio
romanticismo sfrenato non è mai crollato
regalato tantissime attenzione a questa
ragazza
attenzioni quali regalarle rose rosse
aprirle la porta
prestarle la felpa quando aveva freddo
versarle il bicchiere dell'acqua
o mantenerla nel lato esterno della
strada e tante altre
volete davvero sapere com'è andata a
finire
la trovo
una mano
picche
che cosa ho ricevuto una sostanziale
indifferenza gentile attenzione mi mi
accorgo che attribuire all indifferenza
un aggettivo come la gentilezza e un po
paradossale ma in questo caso mi sento
in dovere di farlo
successo questo mi sono subito posto
molte domande
magari non era il momento giusto
o magari questa ragazza non ha
apprezzato le mie buone vere intenzioni
e le proprie su queste ultime che mi
posi mio più grande quesito ma queste
mie buone vere intenzioni al giorno
d'oggi nella mia e nella vostra
generazione sono ormai ritenute vecchie
e quindi non più belle
o magari
questa ragazza era tiepida
anzi mi correggo noi siamo tiepidi non
siamo né caldi e nei freddi ahimè a mio
malincuore
siamo sempre meno in grado di
emozionarci
ognuno è figlio del proprio tempo
nonostante tutto però in ogni scelta che
presi con lei sono sempre rimasto me
stesso
ritengo che non valga la pena cambiare
per qualcuno anzi non val la pena
cambiare per nessuno
prima o poi nella vostra vita vedrete
che arriverà qualcuno in grado di
comprendere tutto
ora vi chiedo di tornare un attimo
all'inizio del discorso vi ricordate di
quel paesaggio in provenza e di quel
ragazzo che passeggiava spensierato nei
sobborghi del paese
quel ragazzo ero io e quello e racconto
reale di ciò che provai per la prima
volta che osservai la notte stellata di
van gogh
in quel preciso istante mi sono accorto
di quanto la mente umana possa spingersi
oltre a qualsiasi cosa
la prossima volta di fronte ad un
tramonto
al posto di fotografarlo per portarlo
sui social fissate l'orizzonte mi
accorgo che bruceranno un po agli occhi
ma continuate a fissarlo
immaginatevi oltre oltre all'orizzonte
ancora più in là ed è proprio lì in
quell'esatto momento che avete percepito
per la prima volta il significato della
parola bellezza ed è quello che sto
chiedendo a voi oggi
accorgete vi meravigliate v